one of the quickest ways that you can
destroy your love for something is to
turn it into a labor most people that
start doing something that they
absolutely love they're a painter they
play the guitar to themselves they do
whatever don't realize what on the other
side of turning that into a job would
perhaps cause a lot of the things that
they love about their love to fall away
and all of these unseen costs to come
through all of the travel all of the
additional time away from friends and
family those start to stack up because
you go I'm no longer being supported by
doing these things on top of that you
have the existential pain of well if I
fail when it's just my thing on the side
it doesn't matter I'm still a plumber
I'm still a father I'm still a whatever
but if I am my Pursuit and I fail at my
Pursuit that means that I am a failure
there is no more existential distance
between how you show up in the world in
your chosen Pursuit and who you are